[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome to the lobby gam spots
weekly hang out every Tuesday at 2 p.m.
right here on Gamespot
that was fun oh my God it's one week to
E3 hype by this time next week Microsoft
Sony Nintendo Ubisoft EA who else Konami
maybe if we're lucky would have had
their press conferences so this week on
the show we're not going to play any
video games we're just going to talk to
people about what we think might happen
this year at the electronic triple this
week I'm delighted to be joined by Mr
Chris Waters as ever hey Danny Seb Forge
finally made it you you're here yeah
from the UK and uh and of course Sean
mcginness hey Danny how's it going very
well how are you I'm doing very well
thank you you didn't come very far I
know I came from like down the hallway
it's not as far as Seb but I still put
forth an effort
indeed we' got a bunch more people from
the UK and we've also got Au folks as
well hop on all right the international
crew we're going to talk about all of
these Microsoft Sony Nintendo and all
that third party stuff in like
individual sections I got you3 here to
talk about Microsoft first of all last
year's E3 for them was not great oh my
God the disaster heard the world it's
like set the tone for the next like year
of of bad news and backtracking for
those guys yeah when you're immediately
flip-flopping on your E3 press
conference two weeks later you did a bad
job yeah so let's talk about first of
all the latest flip-flop we've have
which is connect uh Chris what do you
think they have to do with connect net
or that's like been taken out of the box
oh my God so it's not in the box so what
is that that's that sounds like a vote
of no confidence that's like uh sorry we
you guys really don't want connect oh
cool you don't have to have it but like
connect is a thing that's part of their
system and origin last year you know
they they love to show off how it's like
voice commands touch you know like all
or gesture commands they need to show
the connect is cool which I don't think
they've even done at all they've had a
long time to try and make the connect
cool really have had a long time to make
that's really trendy that's what's
killing me is that like forever we've
been waiting for that like killer hit
connect game or like you know there's
been some really good ones like Dan
Central and stuff were really great but
like it just never happened and I don't
think it's I don't think it's going to
happen on the scale that like wi motion
controls happen because they're not it's
not a core it's not the integral like
way that you interact with the whole
system you know it's it's a peripheral
it's off to the side so I don't think we
should expect the big killer app for it
I think we need to they need to like
lean into this is a cool toy and like
the tech in this is actually pretty
marvelous as demonstrated by all the non
Microsoft product uses that we've seen
of it for years now so I mean people
hacking them on their PCS and stuff
making weird games out of them I don't
think we're going to get like the single
one killer app because there's not quite
the incentive that there used to be
because previously developers who
decided to make a connect game knew that
100% of Xbox Ones had a connect sold
with them maybe not attached and in use
but at least they're sitting in a closet
somewhere now you can buy an Xbox one
without a connect and that installed
base isn't there anymore so people have
to get creative now it's I mean it's not
that it's not there anymore like still
people are still going to have it and
get it and like everything that's in the
works is still in the works right that's
still going to happen harmic Fantasia
two or three Central there you you'll
get your Forza Horizon like be able to
oh
perfect remember when they did that with
the original like when kect was first
announced all the way back all the way
back and you used to be a it was it was
all this stuff it was like break and
Accel remember how it didn't work oh
yeah oh yeah that that's true I really
think they have to I mean you guys maybe
saw in the pre-roll I made a goofy box
art for connect selfie yeah and but I
think that like having some kind of
Studio where you can play around with
the camera and like record yourself over
and over again and then share that video
like that kind of thing like letting
people play around with the connect and
then share that kind of stuff that's
like that's getting your Instagram
that's getting your Vine that's like
tapping into that kind of Social Media
stuff sharing stuff that I think that
connect is a fun tool that could do
that's not going to sell connect but
it's going to make people like use it
and and if somebody gets the console and
then like a Christmas they figure they
they want to drop an extra $100 and
actually pick up the thing on its own
and you know if there's enough uses to
do it then maybe people will right it's
not a matter now of selling the whole
thing it's like you just got to there's
that incremental choice between the base
model Xbox One and the with connect
that's the you kind of have to sell them
on that difference okay let's get
connect eded away they're probably going
to show off there like you know maybe
some sort of bundle the bundle without
maybe they'll bundle G with or something
um they'll have to mention it something
they pedal on that as well don't forget
they can just always B pedal on their
back pedal so don't r that point you're
you're pretty far back yeah yeah it's
fix B I get it okay let's talk about
games then first off Microsoft IP's Halo
5 Guardian was shown off again last week
or we've seen more of it I guess H what
do you think they're going to do in
relation to I'm G to ask you this I'm
you're a big halo fan they the teaser
last year they've announced the official
title Halo 5 guardian and that it's not
coming out till fall next year so it's
just going to be some sexy trailer I
think a quick one it's going to be more
than the teaser if we're lucky we'll get
like 30 seconds of gam playay but I'm
not expecting a full like 10minute long
gameplay demo of a game that comes out
at the end of 2015 yeah that's that's a
long ways off no they're going to show
they're going to they're going to show
it and like wet our whistle for like the
fiction of that and like what was that
weird desert bird thing you know like
cuz why is why is why is Master Chief
wearing a poncho I don't know you tell
me who is that other character that it
looked like a girl but it's not
apparently it's not it's another male
Spartan in the uh box art they reveal or
I don't know if it's just a a promo
image or not that's sort of the mirror
of Master Chief who knows if that has
thematic relevance or not but like you
know they're going to have that but
that's not the only Halo thing that
we're gonna see at the Press presumbly
if they're getting that stuff outed way
as well then I'm not going to focus on
it too much during the actual conference
you would think which H Halo stuff the
fact that they've announced it a month
before noely going to show Halo stuff at
the conference like I absolutely and
it's not what my I was referring to is
not just Halo 5 but there's also uh the
The Collection Halo collection which is
Halos one through four that's coming out
for the Xbox One so they're defin going
to show off some like some of those
glamour shots of like oh you jump into
the system and there's the Halo now it's
in HD that's the first time you ever saw
it now it's an HD buy it again by our
system don't you guys love Halo remember
how it made us in the console World
remember how this is the reason why
we're still here and so it was so
powerful them for them last time around
and this time it seems like Bob Jones
landed 8 in the in the chat just asked
what are Microsoft's exclusives now so
let's go through the ones they haven't
they own that they haven't announced so
Gears of War first of all are we going
to see some sort of gears stuff do you
think I think so yeah I mean they've got
that Vancouver Studio working on it they
brought in Rod Ferguson who worked on uh
Gears of War back at Epic yeah so I mean
they're definitely investing a lot into
the gears franchise they bought that
franchise from epic so I feel like
they're at least going to tease it
somehow whether or not it's a full
gameplay demo I have no idea and if you
figure it's an uphill battle for
Microsoft this year what's going to
distinguish them what's going to like
gain them some ground against Sony
exclusive is one of those big things so
so far these are like remind people why
bought that Xbox 360 why you bought that
Xbox Halo and gears are two huge factors
yeah it's a bit of a shame that they're
leaning on these old IPS they've had for
a long time as well yeah I mean this
would be the fifth game in the gears
franchise counting judgment so does it
have a lot of Sparkle left in it is it
going to like I think so generate
headlines go back go back all the way
back to the beginning and like just
reinvigorate everything that we had when
we first saw it you want Emer day I want
that like I want that back again just a
little light Emer day to get like we
just saw with with Halo you get
something like that you'll get Marcus
Phoenix in in an overall walking through
the desert no he's just carrying a
briefe on the way like that'll be it
guarantee you confirmed I'll put money
on it all right speaking of new IP uh
Quantum break uh that's another sort of
Microsoft TI they've got all the the
game and then they also have the the
weird TV show and stuff that's happening
I know you're a big you know the guys at
remedy pretty well I I do really like
the guys of Remedy mostly just because
they they sent me to see them so like a
long time ago and uh the original Max P
yeah I even got him to do
this yeah the max p face yeah um yeah so
what do you think of uh of quantum break
U I just like to see it because you know
they they didn't do anything really last
year like he kind of came on stage and
and it's what they've been doing like
every time they do a little tease they
do like a little video teaser going hey
we my name's Sam lake at remedy and i'
like it's pretty good Sam Lake it's it's
not that good that's a good that's a
fine finish ACC don't sell yourself
short except for and the um and they
come on and like just go like oh we've
been doing this and we've doing this and
they show a little bit more a little bit
more but not much more and last year's
E3 they kind of didn't really show
anything at all they focus on the TV
stuff a lot yeah or the the high concept
so we got to be really close to
something pretty significant right um
like the last video that they released
made it look great yeah and I want to
play it I really want to play it mostly
because the story is going to be
incredible like the gameplay might be
crap but like the story is going to be
it's the television stuff is a little
bit strange cuz now it seems like it's
not coming out on Xbox first they've
sold it to like ABC or something the
quantum Brak specific television stuff
yeah yeah apparently it's getting
released like similar Caster not just on
regardless of where that ends up you
were definitely going to see television
as a big part of Microsoft press
conference because a because of the time
with qu break but now they've announced
their lineup for like you know that
Spielberg Halo series all these like
there they've they've contracted uh
original series they've got Pilots
they've got shows in production there's
a list of them that stuff that has
nothing to do with video games too yeah
there's like reality shows there's
comedy shows documentary there's
animated shows and that was so that was
part of the that's so much part of their
like Microsoft and Xbox One we are like
your whole entertainment thing and so
now I think they have to F they have to
highlight that in a big way because the
way that Xbox One integrates with TV and
brings original content to the Xbox is
going to be another big differentiator
but isn't that like the problem is that
they've been buying this enter this one
box thing and then what happened was
Sony came out and said screw all that
we're just going to talk about games and
show them up like it's all those parts
of the conferences when they the
Spielberg Halo was so mind numbingly
boring it's like I me the thing is like
the two aren't mutually exclusive video
games and entertainment stuff they can
do the entertainment stuff they just
have to not forget about video games
like they've done for the past couple
years I think as long as like Phil
Spencer is saying a lot of the right
things right now like we have to focus
on games our E3 press conference is
going to be about video games we've
gotten away from that in the past we're
going to try to get back to it so I I
mean honestly I'm fine with them working
on the original stuff there could be
some neat gems in there could be some
turds in there yeah probably yeah uh if
we're betting men and I think we are um
like the weird thing is that at least
Sony is an entertainment company
Microsoft have like no business T you
saying clippy wasn't entertaining clippy
clippy had some gems what's clippy
clippy the little paperclip icon in
office yeah come on oh you say it's
going to be an animated movie oh I see I
think are you writing a letter it looks
like you're writing a it's going to be a
gritty clippy Rebo it's just weird isn't
it it's like Microsoft are making all
this television stuff like they've no
skin in that game ever I mean they you
know the moment they decided to make the
Xbox One a you must have this a One-Stop
shop for entertainment they put
themselves in that game they've made
that leap they're saying you know with
this whole generation even more than
with the Xbox 360 well they were
trending towards it with the 360 and now
they're OB last year we saw they're
going Whole Hog they were showing off
all the sports stuff all the you know
you know TV integration all you plug
your cable box into your Xbox so it is
literally an integral part of your
system that that's their game now
whether they've got the pedigree or not
and I think they really have to show
yeah and let's not forget Microsoft is a
different company now than it was a year
ago there's a new CEO there's new
president of Xbox there's new leadership
so I would imagine they've got new ideas
hopefully they're going to steer the
ship in the right direction is it just
that last year they needed to get the
word out like this is what we're going
to be doing and now that they're in E3
again and the audience who's going to be
watching E3 guys like us who don't give
a crap like for the most part about all
of their entertainment like waft that
they want to throw in they go all right
the words out on that now we can like
you say focus on the games I think
they've been really bad at judging that
mood I feel like they're pretty tone
deaf when it comes to that hopefully
like the the maybe it was a very Don
maty style push that they were doing all
like leaning into that stuff so hard uh
I don't know I guess we'll find out
that's going to be probably the most
interesting thing H they got a bunch of
questions coming in by the way if you
have any questions send them in via the
usual twitch chat Gamespot comments try
and keep them to the section we're in so
we're going to have Sony up in a second
so if any questions about Microsoft send
them in vonic anyone's asking will
Microsoft uh try and pull a Sony card
this year and hype up on Indie Games is
that something that like they they need
to do more now because so they started
that program that ID at Xbox program but
so far they haven't released a lot of
like super exciting indie games at least
Cy is probably because they had Super
Time Force yeah like Super Time Force um
and they did like a re-release of strik
Suit Zero but like they they certainly
haven't released like the breadth of
indie games that Sony has so they have a
lot of catching up to do I hope that
they're going to push Indie Games hard
at E3 because Sony has shown that that
approach can work really well at least
for garnering like Goodwill in the
community yeah and also for like it's
been pretty sparse this year and with
the amount of stuff that are being
delayed until 2015 like the one thing
that's kept me happy with the PS4 is
that at least there seems to be Indie
Games just yeah make you know filling
that Gap a little bit yeah so yeah hope
even in the past couple months I mean
with Child of Light with transistor like
you have these games that are like the
most talked about games on the system
you know for for a chunk significant
chunk of you know the our work a day
week when we're you know talking about
stuff all the time and I think that they
will see Sony's success with that will
see the fact that last year wasn't even
the first time that Sony was really
banging that drum you know they've been
doing it and so I think that is one page
that they are definitely going to take
out of Sony's Playbook and is leaning
into talking about id8 cuz if they have
the programs in place you know and
they've got some movement on them I
think that it really behooves them to
send that message like look we're doing
this guys come to here come to us for
indie games I mean they know that they
screwed up with Indie developers toward
the end of the Xbox 360 whether they
know how to like fix that situation who
knows but at least they're acknowledging
their own faults yeah there massive
problems with like getting games front
and center on that dashboard favor of
all the other business stuff they had um
a couple more games then before we we
finish up here uh let's go pretty
through these pretty quickly uh Sunset
Overdrive is coming out this year it's
one of the few games that's coming out
this year hooray people with orange soda
yeah yeah I don't know that's one of
those games that it's like the the way
that it's being described is so bizarre
which is like Tony Hawk meets like Jet
Set Radio j radio and there's zombies
and there's like energy drinks and stuff
like that and Ted price is involved yeah
but like I just can't wrap my head
around that game without piing a
controller because it's such weird
combination of ideas and I feel like
that's probably something that Insomniac
and Microsoft are struggling with right
now is just conveying what makes this
game cool you can show that game in
action but I think you with a game like
that that's a little weird like you have
to show you have to show something that
channels the player experience so the
players have something to hook on to
otherwise you just end there's a reason
we've been making the joke that that
game looks like a '90s Go-Gurt
commercial it does you know it just has
that overthe toop aesthetic and it's
easy to joke about but it could be
really fun to play Sonia has a great
pedigree yeah absolutely Crackdown was
fun so well okay what about what about
Crackdown 3 yeah could we see a
Crackdown three do you think uh
Crackdown 2 was kind of a wet fart of a
game uh I don't kind of more of the I
mean I would love to see a game on the
caliber on the level of Crackdown one
which is excellent refreshing super fun
1080 60p agent agent agent agent we need
you to collect all these even better
looking orbs jump to the top of a build
agent yeah is is is cracked down a
product of its time could like a new cuz
it was very much like baby steps open
world that Arrow when everyone was just
Mak where yeah does a new Crackdown
bring anything to the table do you think
as long as it brings something new to
the table which is something that
Crackdown 2 did not do it was just a
paint by numbers repeat of the original
game yeah I mean with there's so many
games now that are that you've got off
prototype there's Infamous there's these
great superpowered open World Games yeah
you really got to going to have to carve
out a significant Niche if you want want
to bring that crack G
back once you got that then then you're
in you're sh in a couple more before we
finish up rise to any interest in a
second
Rise where does this R where did this
rumor come from Rise two it's not going
to happen this soon because they never
would have because all that technology
it looks pretty repeatable it looks like
they can push in another one of those
did anyone get to the end of that game
and go I need more I need CCH people did
when will I'm pretty sure Kevin played
that game like three times he like liked
it but he gave it like a four or five or
something but he just kept playing it
because it's it's a very so rise too if
they've got the tech they've got this
you know they can render a beautiful
Roman world what should that game be it
shouldn't be the linear beat him up
should it be uh should it be a
multiplayer melee game should it like
should it be you know troop management
like back up back out to the Supreme
Commander View and you're like sending
your fail lankes around yeah I don't I
don't know I got no answer that find out
E3 um couple what a rare that we've
connect Sports Rivals come out when I
was talking to them back a couple of
months ago it sounded very much like
they were waiting for Microsoft to give
them the opportunity to go back to one
of their franchises yeah what do you
think would be a good play for them next
well the beginning of the 360 they came
out with perfect dark zero right so
let's fix that yeah fix that you want a
perfect dark yeah I'd love that you want
a more perfect not imperfect dark yeah
that work for me I think this is going
to sound weird but banjo kazui nuts and
bolts it was a very it was a very
open-ended game where you could like
craft your own vehicle and it had its
own weird like behavioral patterns
depending on how you assembled it and I
think that Taps into a lot of what makes
games like Minecraft appealing these
days so I think now is a good time for
them to bring that back and try to do it
even better than it did before do you
want to see some more Viva Pata oh my
God they made that game for children
there was a cartoon with it it was a
brilliant game then it's perfect but
that game was not for I feel like
whoever was making that that's Microsoft
making the television show and thing
again it's like the game with the TV
show and they were so like uncompatible
one was for 5-year-olds and one was for
like 25 year olds would loads of time
you get these stupid chocolate hamsters
to have sex with each other and those
people loved it yeah and those 25y olds
are now however old we are and so yes
they should bring back I mean that has
super Nostalgia value for a lot of
people and you know also that kind of
open creativity mode that I reach out
and I pick up my little what's a dumb
Viva Pinata animal name the chocolate
hamsters who have sex with each other
pick up two chocolate hamsters and mash
them together yeah great fa
Legends uh that one looks kind of
interesting only because it's just not a
fable game though like why why even call
it a fable game because it's said in
albian and looks like a fable game and
her it's well it's a Dungeon Crawler
though it's not like a story Choice
driven RPG it's like a co-op Dungeon
Crawler it's so but you can play as the
villain that's true and you can mess
with dudes it's kind of got a little bit
of the Evolve thing if you squint hard
enough and really lie to yourself well
evolve is a game we're going to talk
about later but for now thank you all
for coming on and talking about
Microsoft rumors first party video games
and all that nonsense uh yeah thanks
very much now let's give away some stuff
uh we've got a bunch of uh stuff we're
going to give away some we've given away
some stuff and we got new stuff to give
away first of all I want to say we've
got all of these sweet razor you hold
the stuff hold the stuff the Stu give me
the big one we giving away the mouse and
that headset and
laptop release the Kraken so we we had a
up and we got this one here yeah so
first second and third prize oh sorry
second third and fourth prize winning
this first prize wins a laptop and the
two of these we don't have the laptop
out here cuz it's in like a really
boring looking box uh thanks to Razer
for sorting us out with those we had a
competition via our Gamespot Twitter
account earlier in the week and later on
we're going to have a look at the
winners of those uh but for now we also
have a giveaway we did earlier in the
week for wallstar uh which is coming out
today I believe it's today Kevin vard's
playing it have you guys been talking to
him about it no at all been streaming it
a ton though yeah play a bunch of it um
so his review is I guess is a review in
progress probably going to go up usually
happens for the MMOs yeah he's going to
get that done before we head down to E3
because there's a very slim chance he'll
have a review finish by E3 that's right
yeah good point uh so we have uh 10
copies of the digital deluxe version
thanks to our friends at carbine for
that uh do we have the names can we
stick them up on screen now all those we
can't can I list I can save them with my
with my you save them s Danny like I've
I've always wanted to be on this show
and I like how I can uh I can hear Mary
in your ear going do we have the names
no I can just hear it yeah but PE behind
all right so the winners fire and fly
one good fire andly there rap Kitty
nanana 7 J fuse 1212 Kenby 6870 I love
that guy too much onesie unemployed Jedi
nice I know it's really hard unemployed
X
Jedi Jedi used to be a Jedi when he was
employed yeah things didn't work out for
him uh HB m e Manuel and uh not ant one
and yeah you can take the last one no
that's
yours
887 no what is what is what's that in
Irish no that's not an Irish you're
thinking of NE and that's not what that
is say it NE 87 longest giveaway ever
thank you very much you're the best
thanks
for review of uh wallar will be out on
gayot.com later in the week and those
folks uh make sure you're following us
so we can send you those codes via DM
all right we'll be back in a second
Microsoft's over and next we're going to
talk about Sony let's go have a look at
a wallstar
trailer
I want to tell you about a place a place
called
Nexus Nexus bloody Rod I had in Nexus a
Lost Paradise it be hidden away for
thousands of years till we found it and
how we it's nice having a place to
settle down I mean it's about time then
civilization be returned to the world
Nexus is our Legacy and it is imperative
that we discover what happened to the El
once the most advanced race in Galactic
history unlocking their secrets will now
require total Destruction it's warm and
it ain't going to be pretty see the
thing
is nothing here is what it
seems Nexus has a terrible Secret
[Music]
and
now we're so glad you have
[Music]
come rated T4
welcome back to gam spots E3 prediction
show right here on the lobby Daniel
dwire joined by Chris Waters now we've
got Martin Gaston from the UK say
something in an English accent oh hello
thank you Martin and of course Justin
haal as well games spot news editor GLE
cool accent you have a wonderful ACC a
wonderful cool accent used to it and you
know lots about Sony which is why you
have you here we're going to talk about
Sony predictions they had a pretty good
E3 last year is that fair to say they
did
right it's still amazing that people are
still talking about that and you know
that the PlayStation 4 is just kind of
still going from that momentum of of
basically trouncing the Xbox One and
like everything that Xbox said in their
press conference you know Sony just came
out and said uh no DRM uh you know you
want to use used games we're going to do
that also here's the price and it's $100
less than their system and it's still
going strong so isn't didn't wasn't it
more maybe much of a case that last year
all Sony really did was react to What
Microsoft did badly well they didn't
even have to react they just went we're
stay the same you know the things you
can do on PlayStation 3 that that's also
what PlayStation 4 does we're just not
going to blow it like Microsoft did all
and they didn't no they didn't they did
not blow it the best thing I heard of e3
last year the best and it's probably not
even true at all is the there was like a
hundred different slides for that last
slide of the price they had rehearsed
all kinds of prices cuz they were just
sitting there waiting for the actual
price so they had it they they could
have gone probably down to $5 to a
million doar they had slides for all of
it and as soon as Microsoft put it on
they were like all
right that one and then went with that
and I don't know if that's true but I
want it to be true because that's the
spirit that Sony has now and I love that
it's maybe it's more like in sitcoms
where you you film multiple scenes of an
angle or multiple angles from for a
different scene with different
characters just so nobody really knows
except for the person on stage who's
going to Ral it well like even the the
the trailer they had where they did the
how you share games with your friends
where it was Adam boy and Shu just
handing the game to each other that was
recorded the day before the press
conference in the backstage area behind
the stage we spoke about that at games
com we and that video has got like
millions of views like to put into
perspective like Sony has teams and
teams of people who work fulltime
putting together promotional videos and
spending Millions spending millions and
they they sit in meetings for like weeks
and weeks going I guess we'll do this
shot and then we'll do this shot and
then suddenly these two Executives go
and you like and the view C shoot it's
like 19 million views or something on
YouTube it's incredible but we've had a
whole year for Xbox to to turn things
around like they have changed their
policies they finally reduced the price
they've gotten rid of connect which
nobody really cared about anyway so I
mean going into this E3 Sony just can't
do the the same thing again because they
don't have a Microsoft to react against
who's just being batshit insane they
they have to do something and what do
they have to do but if there so there's
no like punch back right there's no
there's not they're not set up for this
kind of dramatic
moment in the way and I don't think that
you know that's one of the most dramatic
moments for your E3 memorable Moments
video that I think we've seen at any E3
yeah Tot but I mean do you think they
could get away with just staying the
course you know with showing the same
kind of ratio of big games to Indie
Games to PlayStation Now to you know
living room stuff and then could they
just sort of carry it on and not not
lose lose their footing well for me the
PlayStation Now price is something
that's going to be really important and
that's some place where we don't really
know what Xbox is going to do they've
been talking about making the Xbox One
compatible with you know previous games
and the PlayStation's answer has been
whatever PlayStation Now is going to be
whatever that price is going to be and
if it's something you know that's tied
in with PlayStation Plus which we
already have a subscription to like
that'll be awesome and that will be a
huge bombshell like you just have access
to these games because you're a plus
subscriber making that even sweeter but
if they make it something if if XBox
comes out and says and we're going to
make all of our X content uh available
if you're an Xbox Live subscriber but
playst goes and here's a separate
service and it's $20 a month but you get
access to old games that's not going to
be quite the the same impact well let's
talk about the actual games the first
party stuff that they can bring to
disable uh first of all I want to talk
to Martin about Drive Club this so you
you went over to the studio only a
couple of weeks ago right it's a Ron
Corn where's Ron Corn sounds like a
really Liverpool really yes nice that
magical um it rained real bad The
Beetles there the spirit of the Beet
there go did any of you play Drive Club
last year no okay I'm going to be I'm
going to be honest it was bad okay bad
game it was last year or or recently
last year E3 last year it it it was a
bad game okay it wasn't fun the handling
was all messed up and it just didn't it
didn't have anything so when they were
like go do you want to come to runor and
play Drive Club I was like yes but when
I last played this game wasn't very good
and oh it's better now and I'm like
whatever and so you know we go up there
and I'm playing it and I'm like it's
actually better now it is better now now
I find Hash drivy Club # Dro Club i'
been the whole thing about it a bit
difficult yeah like I don't think with
all this like social thing I don't think
that actually really matters like I
think that's to be expected now that's
like a an expected feature yeah
multiplayer in some aspects like
leaderboards and stuff is like part and
parcel of driving games yeah so leading
on that I think is a bit silly cuz
everyone's going like yeah you know
whatever yeah driver tires yeah like and
at least the driver tire things is
something right that's something new so
that's something for has but the the
handling of Drive Club was was really
fun it was it was a fun game to play and
I want it I really want it to to do well
because I also believe that if it
doesn't do well but
do they do they need another driving uh
franchise like that they have Gran
Turismo need for
they have one grand chismo every 17
years right that's and in
2029 out it's going to be fantastic it's
going to be great well but they'll
release two demo versions First full
price and then eventually prolog and
prap that's one do uh but I think an
arcade
racer is a good thing to have like the
last div speed and there's not one
coming out this year I think a first
party arcade eracer is a a good thing
for Sony to have in in their stable yeah
if you will allow me to use that
probably horrible executive buet uh but
it's not the lead it's not like the it's
not the crown je right so it's in there
but they it's not going to I feel like
you can only see so it's so hard to
dazzle with something like that so what
is then for Sony is it like the last is
it like what's what's the what's the
power card at this stage cuz like media
molecule might be working on something
we don't know uh presumably they are
rare are probably Med molecule has come
out and they've said we're not going to
show anything at e33 Medi molecule they
had that really cool direct when you
know when the PlayStation 4 was
announced with like that kind of weird
music game yeah it was the vag
description of a game I've ever seen
where you make the game by doing this
because so what what's the big one now
is it like is it deep down or is it
Project Beast or is it like is it Last
Guardian because all I keep hearing is
the Last Guardian is like be good set
for this year this is like the seventh
year that they haven't talked about the
last guardians but this is the one year
where it sounds like it actually might
be show it's either there this year yeah
or it's gone or it's not happen totally
yeah yeah okay they either they either
took it away a couple years ago and said
guys make it a PS4 game and PS try not
to you know not finish it again uh or
it's gone yeah that that is what I
believe I mean I don't know but I it
must be that must that makes sense right
that makes sense so if it's going to be
there that would make sense why it
hasn't been here why they held off
exactly and if it's going to be there
it's going to make a splash I mean you
could show something that is essentially
no longer or more complicated than what
we saw so many years ago and I think
people would still freak out with
delight and anticipation because they're
finally getting it dude I would feel so
Wiggly be like oh my God I'm freaking
out that's one of the things that makes
this so so exciting though is that you
know amidst all of these leaks that
we've had the Battlefield Hardline all
of the the whole trailer for that come
out so many of these games we already
know about whereas Sony like what are
these Studios working on they have so
many internal studios are they keeping
it a secret that's awesome just got a
question here from Mor who's asking new
uh God of War what do you think like
what are son Sony Santa Monica working
on they have to they've got Cory back
Cory Cory yeah right Cory Booker
actually mayor of New barro right it's
barro I always don't I always I always
know his name as barro and I'm like no
barck is is thater from Lord ring Mor
combat that's him character I must be
wrong with that but no it is they've got
he's got him back he was like the God of
War I dude and God of War II is the best
one like there's the others there's God
of War II right it's to have him back is
really good and I want it to be in uip
like I want maybe spiritual successor or
something but like God of War cing God
of peace goddess of war goddess of war
fine go God of War carding fine just
something like something new but they
they've got him back and that's got to
be exciting well we talked about
exclusives so much with Microsoft I mean
what are the Sony exclusives Uncharted
God of War is a huge one and of course
Uncharted which were like all but
guaranteed to see a significant amount
of and don't forget with this Uncharted
now that they've got the they've got
Neil drugman and Bruce Dr back and
they're overseeing it they can now go
from the creators of The Last of Us oh
yeah they can from the creators of The
Last of Us Then you one other because I
actually think what's happened now is
The Last of Us is is the bigger game
yeah I think it's got more cache which
core Gamers anyway and you everyone
going oh no the crazy oh my God but I
don't want more Last of Us like I I want
that to be a standalone experience
that's that's just there that was a
great experience now please do something
different I think tonally they're pretty
much like on opposite ends of the
spectrum as well one's like this
bombastic action Trope you know or you
know adventure and then the other one is
a depressing
slog there's so many things they're
going to be able to take from that that
work really well in the last of us like
from the shooting mechanics yeah
mechanically it's wonderful and putting
those in Uncharted oh finally please
finally you're going to fix all these
things that I really you don't want you
want you want Drake to be more of a like
really got to work hard to like land a
shot not his like free wheel and like
pop it up I don't want to walk into a
room and oh here's 50 enemies that you
have to kill then four 40 more yeah just
kind of speaking of walking into room
and killing 50 enemies will there be a
new Kill Zone this year I know no no I
hope not one cuz I don't like Killzone
what a gorilla working on then theyve
they've been working on a new IP for
ages okay they've been saying oh we've
got our new RP guys since like 2010
they've been doing this a long time so
it better be good Last
Guardian it's actually set onas It's the
Last Guardian except now it's actually
the the guardian animal thing is
actually some sort of Nazi and kill it
you blow up its own Planet but you're
the good guys and you wear it head so it
doesn't matter that story worked really
well for Killzone I don't see why they
would not want to replic the rich
eviction of it's so hot right now
genocide Killzone coming soon um let's
talk about hardware for a second Vita
are they gonna show off stuff for the
Vita where where is the Vita at the
moment like 3DS is selling really well
Vita seems to have it seemed dead in the
water real early and I feel like in the
past 6 to n months since the PlayStation
4 has come out it's actually been given
a new lease of life that PlayStation
Plus the you know giving people free
games like if you own a Playstation 3
there's no reason not to own another
piece of this Hardware because you're
just getting free games every month for
it as well and I think that's actually
something that's helped the VA a lot but
there's got to be some new games some
new cool stuff that they're going to
show and I'm really hoping for something
like PaRappa the Rapper like bringing
back like a really cool music purely
music focused experience yeah what other
type of old IPS like that like will we
see God this is so horrible to say will
we see a wipe out that's horrible to say
I just feel horrible to say like will
they pull it away because they've
obviously shut down you know talk about
Sony Studios in Liverpool that might be
on their last bread like they shut down
those guys they slow in that IP it seems
like they release a new WIP game every
couple of Years anyway yeah I don't know
about the wipe out franchise but I do
think that there is going to be a ton of
Vita stuff at this press conference yeah
yeah know no wipe it not a big wipe
motor do you uh do you have any uh motor
was really good yeah but then that
wasn't okay yeah what about a new new
motor storm game for the
PS4 is there ring games I feel like
racing games don't well they don't grab
me I'll say I said it with Drive Club
and I I don't know how much of that is
my own personal perspective versus just
like they occupy such a specific Niche
although when you talk about the niche
between Drive Club and Motor Storm it's
not that specific it's pretty broad yeah
what big part carding to Little Big
Planet carding to Mod Nation races why
you on this carding kick I don't know
cuz Sony seemed to be they relas
freaking released three card games in
one Mario Kart 8 did really well got to
capture that lightning in a bottle fair
enough do you think they'll announce a
PS4 VA bundle that that was a rumor last
year that never came to I think that was
wishful thinking last last year more
than a rumor but I think if we' learn
anything from the past year it's it's
maybe not to
bundle all of your
stuff yeah if they did a bundle it would
be100 $200 more expensive and that would
kind of defeat the whole like oh we're
cheaper than Xbox one which they've
already aren't quite there anymore uh
okay Dark Souls ripoffs Project B deep
down maybe it's unfair to say that a bit
those games Project based well no you
can't call it a ripoff it's from from
software yeah it's from from from from
yeah the most exciting game I've seen in
ages and all I've seen is some weird
gifts yeah CH leaks I am I am so ready
to see that game and that's that's a
very E3 game if you ask me because you
know I mean all of us sitting there
watching E3 we're you know that's the
kind of game that
is would be made to appeal to us that
that is again you know Tom it's not for
the newspapers Tom M show be doing back
flips around the Gamespot he get so
agile whenever Dark Souls is mentioned
he will be
mind if that happens and Spelunky too is
announced uh for Vita uh he might just
lose his goddamn mind uh I'm trying to
think what else um well one thing I
don't think we're going to see at all is
Project Morpheus we saw that you know GC
do you think they're not going to show
much not going to show it at all huh no
I if they do maybe it'll be over at the
booth like here's you can try out the
thing that we showed off at GDC but so
for the people who don't know this is
their virtual reality headset proprietry
one that they're making themselves H has
there been much in the way of like
discussions about how that is that going
to be specifically for the PlayStation
infrastructure like are they going to go
down the PC route is it you they haven't
talked about it a lot um I I would
assume that this is going to be a
PlayStation 4 only kind of device this
isn't going to be coming to PC but you
know we don't really know presumably
though if they're doing that then
they're going to have to like the
connects they're going to have to make
software reasons for people to buy it
like they're going to have to start
making games that are made either
specifically for or at least are
additive with the with the Morpheus do
you see that being a section in the
Press conference maybe not not at the
press conference like I think the press
conference is going to focus on the the
more immediate than now in the 2015 and
this stuff isn't going to be ready by
2015 even Oculus isn't I just don't
think we'll see any Mor in fact what
what I think we'll do is they'll they'll
talk about how well the PlayStation has
done they'll have a new slide no they
can't do the numbers thing again they
stopped doing that last year where they
SP 15 minutes of pie
charts they will just go their numbers
are too good not to show sold 9 million
it's let's move on but 9 million
shipped and sold yeah and then they they
will just move on so they'll update with
that and they'll talk about how you know
they they've got the present sorted and
they will be a bit like and we're also
you know we're investing in the future
and then like a Morpheus thing will
appear in the background and we're still
sort of making it so they move on to
laen Fishburn will come out sitting on a
chair that does not look dissimilar to
this one and say yeah well he he likes
to
shill um what else Sony I'm trying to
think there was one thing I'm tipping my
tongue there and it's gone
gone there's a bunch of Sony questions
there's a bunch of Sony questions thank
you the voice in my head oh Crash
Bandicoot question mark good
call yeah I would love it I you're the
one who said PaRappa the Rapper might
come back I I I'm a bigger fan i i a
rhythm game fan like if Dance Central or
or Rock Band came back like I would buy
more guitar peripherals just to play
Rock Band I love music games more
platforming that's that's what I play
Mario for that's what I wanted to ask
sorry I got it back now I got my dra
back last year there was a bunch of
weird indie games that came out of
nowhere that shadow of the Beast
announcement was the strangest thing
seen in my life at Gamescom what other
weird do you think there's going to be
any more weird Indie stuff oh absolutely
it's all going to be Triple A Indies now
but I'm wondering is they're going to
because there's a lot of indie games
that at the moment of like like no man's
Sky which nobody knows what platform
they're coming out on do you think it
might be a thing where Microsoft and son
you're going to try and grab some of
those for timeing exclusives I really do
oh definitely and Indies were such a
huge part of of their messaging last
year they're they're going to continue
to to embrace that I think we're going
to see even more cool Indie stuff that
that they both Microsoft and Sony have
been able to snatch up and I really
don't want it to be exclusive I want it
to come to as many platforms as possible
because I want to be able to play it on
everything well I think the phrase timed
exclusive is totally one we're going to
hear a lot or at least is going to be
true about a lot of games this year
because we I feel like with so many of
these Indie Games you're past the point
where uh one company is just buying them
outright yeah you know they're's like
look on the balance you know if we can
get exclusivity for the first three
months and that's when people are hyped
about it that's going to give us a
significant share and then you know who
knows what the the business logic is
behind it for the Creator and for the
publisher but I think timed exclusives
are much more a thing that you see with
this caliber game and certainly
something that both the those these two
big Publishers are going to be leaning
hard into for E3 it works great for them
because Sony or Microsoft can offer them
promotion they can say look we can put
you bang in the center of the of our
respective stores and people will will
you know like visibility is is a big
deal for for people making you know
smaller games understandably so and do
you remember when do you remember when
sum of arcade was good like years and
years and years ago when Xbox Live sum
of arcade was was was actually
good Microsoft must before the days of
Kingdom for keelings pretty when they
killed it yeah recer came so getting
back to that because even like and the
funny thing is the poster child for the
success of Microsoft Indies a lot of the
time was Super Meat Boy and that game
actually had a T of time trying to get
exposure on that service as well but but
just when you'd have like Geometry Wars
2 and Shadow complex and other games I'm
forgetting because there's lots of
Lights On Me U Charles H you know when
summer arcade was good it was so good
and I long I know this is the Sony bit
but just for either of those things you
know maybe Sony can have Autumn of
PlayStation store or whatever I don't
know but
like and we're not going to know what's
good until until we get there like those
are the games we have to try out like
you see the demo and you're like well
that's kind of quirky and fun but then
you play it and you're like oh my God
this is so awesome cool all right
gentlemen thank you so much for coming
on talking a bunch of Sony mess uh
Microsoft and Sony are probably going to
be the most interesting end of the two
of them especially after what happened
last year uh there's been a bunch of
games announced and leaked over the past
month one of which actually bizarrely we
had um Jeff gersman from Giant Bomb on
the couch about two weeks ago and you
remember at the end of that segment I
said what's the game you're looking
forward to most at E3 and he says you
know but I can't tell you yes well
apparently a trailer was released for
this week so uh we'll be back in a
second with some chat about Nintendo but
first of all here's the trailer for the
new Mortal
Kombat
[Music]
fight I'mma tell you that you're not my
competition I'm always win throw me in
and I'm going in i a running I'm come to
you can get to talk about it cuz I
really live it night on the mission no
fear no hope in my vision don't know
interv you wait on theide even come out
them out and
[Music]
be you make me you to be brave and step
up with your crew is too scary CU I'm
too legendary what we go hard for I'm
rocking your block you once you get
knocked off I'm taking your place I'm
making my property maybe G
you
only
weak any time I get into it I be looking
at I'm looking in the condition be
critical L than original the end of you
who's
next finish
[Music]
him get over
here Mortal Kombat X everyone do X's I
can't believe that's that's our intro to
talking about Nintendo seriously
Nintendo we like to keep a nice and uh
chalk and cheese on on on the lobby here
uh I'm joined today by Tom McShay and
Jess McDonald and Ed Tran hi Dan how you
doing what's up thank you very much for
coming over to San Francisco pre E3 and
hanging out with us talk about Nintendo
yeah we're going to talk about Nintendo
productions for E3 uh hands up if you
own a Wii
U are you kidding me what I I thought
you were no you play so much Wii U in
the office I play so
much I play so much Wii U that's the
thing that's funny that's really
embarrassing whatever so Nintendo
historically have done press conferences
like uh Microsoft and Sony uh this year
much like last year they are opting to
have their own little sort of Suare off
to the side yeah um Tom are Nintendo
relevant in the grander scheme of video
games still yes next question no they
totally are like I know what you mean
there's like Nintendo have always been
sitting on the periphery and sort of
doing their own thing but now it seems
like they're really like the peripher is
like over there they're having a hard
time they're having a h but they're
still Nintendo they still got their
franchises and to be honest I think as
much as we would all love to say and
keep saying IP new IP from Nintendo
would be so cool I think at the same
time we're all kind of like yeah I would
totally buy a great new Zelda game and I
totally just bought Mario Kart and I
think I think Nintendo knew that I think
like they're kind of like oh yep IP is
gonna happen but I I wonder if it's ever
going to be not just about the big
franchises well everyone complains about
Nintendo's like core franchises and like
not in innovating or whatever but they
always innovate like within those
franchises so like Mario always does
something new each time marot has like
more
items it
Z second hle so we we've seen it in the
UK I think the sales for the Wii U
Hardware have gone up 600% week on week
off the back of Mario Kart so do you
think like that's all they need to do
like you you reviewed Mario Kart for I
mean it was it's the same figures when
um Super 3D Mario World yes I can't
remember the name of that game Super
Mario 3D World came out last year it
went up like 600% but it's like it
without the steady flow you're going to
get the the hardcore and then you know
some of the the ancillary fans getting
it but yeah the system still only sold
like 7 million worldwide like it's not
it's not a popular system right now so
okay let's talk about games what games
could they make that would or announc
this year that would get people to hop
back on board on the Wii U on the Wii U
specifically absolutely nothing really I
don't it's it's so hard to turn around
public perception and at this point it's
like oh it's old hardware and it doesn't
do anything that much new or different
and I think that they're they're in a
position where they kind of need to
release new hardware sooner rather than
later which is super sad I mean I feel
like they're they're in a place where if
Mario Kart 8 wasn't going to do it I
don't think anything else is going to do
Super Smash Brothers would be good well
okay so my thing is I am one of those
people who will buy a system if there's
games on it that I want and there can be
cuz Nintendo had that whole thing where
they were like look one game can make a
system and I actually buy into that I
got the 3DS for the Legend of Zelda
League Between Worlds because it was
phenomenal it was my favorite game of
last year okay gam spots 2013 game I
bought it because it was a gold 3DS with
a Triforce on it but yeah I bought it in
the bundle and that's why I'm not
surprised so many people got the Wii U
with the Mario Kart what did they say um
75% of sales of that title in the UK
were bought within the bundle people
being like yep all right I'll buy a Wii
U now but I kind of agree I think I I
think they might be at the end of the
Rope you can't say that Mario Kart 8 is
not a fantastic game
no probably the second best console
Mario what else can they do no for the
okay so you already own one right so
Jess you don't yes you might if there is
a game that might your interest what
would that game be and a new Zelda for
instance so I had the my Nintendo 64
Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time is like
my baby like if I could have that kind
of experience on a Wii U yeah I probably
buy one I think if I was a Mario Kart 8
person then I would have bought Mario
Kart 8 bundle that would have been my
thing but yeah at the same time it's
kind of dating right now the way you
like next to the Xbox One and the
PS4 TR if they announce a new Zelda I'll
still be quite skeptical cuz I did not
enjoy either of the Wii zeldas yeah see
that's true yeah I enjoyed uh Link
Between Worlds and I love my I love wi
Waker but not a fan so what what would
you like to see as a fan and an owner of
a of a Wii U Mario Galaxy 3 really oh
man Mario Sunshine 2 space we had a
bunch of people in the comments asking
for Mario Sunshine yeah but Sunshine was
very good need that flood pack back I'm
in the exact I don't ever want another
galaxy cuz I think 2 is basically
Perfection I gave it a 10 I don't think
you can make a better game I I defy
every developer out there make a better
3D platform I don't think it's possible
three words for the best Nintendo
strategy year of Waluigi oh no now the
messed up thing is that now we've got
all these weird like rap videos with
Luigi and this is much more hyped than
you ever got in this actual Year of
Luigi uh so it looks like a new Zelda
seems to be like a dead set like there
so much rumor don't think the new Zelda
will be Wii U exclusive if it comes to
Wii U this is my this is my crazy
prediction so here's the thing what
could I possibly come add on their next
platform I I get really bummed out when
people don't have a chance to buy an
awesome exclusive game and there's like
7 million Wii U's out there so we U
Zelda would not sell that much so I
think if it does come out it'll be like
Twilight how it was cross generational
and then it was it was for we and for
Twilight Princess was shown at like E3 3
years running or something wasn't that
like they just they kept it debuted in e
3 2005 and then came out a couple years
later yeah or something like that I
don't know but it's like I I don't I
think that if Zola went to the Wii U
alone it would almost be amazing and
then wither and die there without like
people playing it and that makes me sad
so are you on board with the there might
be Hardware this year or I I do I think
I think I think they need to come out
with something next next year or
something they need to start start doing
stuff let's talk about their other
Hardware than 3DS is but doing W success
like ever since the DS light came out
and kind of before that as well that
console that hand has just dominated the
handale market um how what do you think
is next for the 3DS is it still fine as
a piece of Hardware itself who owns who
owns a hands up for only 3DS see I don't
but I always have the office one yeah so
you yeah you have do you have an n6 this
is what
happeny do you play video games I've
played so many video games that's the
thing that's crazy the 3DS is weird cuz
it has one awesome game every like three
months but then it kind of that's how I
feel about that's how I feel about the
Wii U like as someone who owns like
multiple consoles I'm okay with having
one big Wii U game every once in a while
yeah CU Mario Kart 8 is like just about
the most fun game this year I don't
think played anything that much but yeah
then there's going to be a dry spell and
then yeah so are you guys are you guys
still playing with your 3DS's what have
you played most recently that like the
game that we're showing right now that
Kirby game is amazing I love that I got
100% And I didn't even review it I just
plowed through the game it's amazing
yeah I mean I'm like I'm big on the
major franchises and I'm the same like
I'm happy to just I'm stuck with uh Link
Between Worlds I was playing because
it's my handheld game so I was playing
that between at the same time as playing
games on my PC and um yeah and that's
fine and I'll I'll go through and I'll
play that for a few weeks or however
long it takes and then I'm I'm kind of
okay to put aside handheld console for a
while and just be like okay well then
and now I'm like okay cool well I want
Pokémon so then I'm going to I'm going
to get on the bandwagon really late and
I've gotten myself Pokemon and it's like
well now I'm going to play that for a
while and cuz I've got a verer as well
which sort of does the same thing like
let's play sometimes and then is it not
any games I want for a while so there's
like a thing uh Nintendo's having like a
90 minute conversation with the Press
about a 3DS game just one one of them
there's going to be two of these things
one of them is for smash BRS we already
know the other one's unannounced yeah
okay so there's like a a game that
warrants a 90 minute discussion coming
out of the 3DS and we don't know about
what would you hypothesize that would be
well it's it's obvious to say like I
want a new IP like I want Metroid
Metroid I really bad okay that's all I
want is a new Metroid it's been years
and the Ninja Theory one had
questionable story elements yeah no more
vario suits no more vario suits that you
don't turn on until the man
tells there's a lot lots of chat about a
new Metroid uh M was asking do you think
new Advanced Wars oh my God be great
came out last year that's also
intelligent systems and fire I don't
know if you guys played it yeah is is
amazing I've never played one before and
I loved it the strength of that yeah
maybe more tactics games like that yeah
it's perfect for the handhelds yeah a
good system like just as it is like I I
really I do prefer the 3DS to the VA
like the way it feels it's just like
it's such a solid piece of hardware and
I think that's always going to run in
the 3DS's favor so do you think they're
going to like maybe maybe that's what
happens maybe they just focus more in
the 3DS instead of the the wiii cuz the
problem the Wii U has at the moment is
that it's not just F like like exactly
like you said the 3DS is fighting the
Vita the Wii U is fighting the PS4 the
Xbox One the two old generation ones and
the PC my whole my whole thing is I want
them to kill both the 3DS and the Wii U
at the same time and then release a new
system this is terrible relas a new
system some people just want to see the
world burn the dep portable system that
plugs in your TV so because all because
right now you have all these Nintendo
teams competing against themselves
basically cuz it's like they're making a
Zelda on the portable and a Zelda on the
console and it's just like if they could
all be in one place and there's just one
Nintendo platform and it's got every
amazing game you could ever want I that
sounds pretty good to me you're crazy
you know it's just crazy enough work you
own a Wii U name a Wii U game that's
coming out this year that you're excited
about Smash Brothers okay name a second
one Smash Brothers Smash Brothers the
big one for me B of two okay yes my
apolog super gy about
too H High rule Warriors as well isn't
that not about that that's an odd one it
sucks cuz it's like high rule uh oh
interesting though that will sell them a
metric ton of consoles in Japan really
they love the dasty war nuts for it wi
is selling as well as like the PS4 in
Japan so it's doing all right over there
yeah is that team ninja as well Warriors
all right so it's team ninja uh Tech no
well they're working with team oh that's
what it is yeah yeah okay so it's s a
little bit shaky for for uh I am so
excited for Nintendo what they're going
to show because like we don't know what
Retro Studios is making okay but we know
that whatever they're working is going
to be a masterpiece cuz that's
everything that touches gold that's
right I just want the come back I just
want to see Nintendo cuz when they pull
it out of the bag God they pull it out
of the bag I know and they're like
having a live stream throughout the
entire show and the Treehouse thing is
that right I don't know can you like
revealing doing a live doing the hot
presentation from a tree house outside
LA Live oh no at their booth and they're
uh dropping reveals throughout the show
oh really during the actual that and
everything okay cool why haven't they
made a new Pokemon game for the Wii U
why has there not been Pokemon snap it's
a freaking tablet snap they're going to
show off the whatever uses the nearfield
communication stuff with the wi U I
guess I mean Smash Brothers is but
there's probably be a game built around
that we get the harbe the Vitality
sensor I hope so I don't know
that killer Hardware that they've been
waiting for yes okay so it's it's a sort
of a sad side situation no because being
said the conversation seems to be like
either you you you stop and rebuild or
we are stuck with like sort of wet wet
blanket releases for the
next I mean it's true but at the same
time when Nintendo releases a game they
release you know Game of the Year from
last year they released Mario Kart 8 so
it's like they're they're super relevant
at your first question they make the
best games they do amazing games okay
well hopefully I don't think there's
anyone on this couch or anyone watching
uh except for Fanboys that wouldn't want
Nintendo to pull something out of the
bag this year so fingers crossed H
thanks very much guys for coming on uh
we'll be back in a couple of minutes
we're going to talk about PC stuff and
all third party uh developers as well if
you have any questions make sure to put
them in the chat but for now we're going
to check out a trailer for The
Batman
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to gamespot's E3
prediction show we've already talked
about Nintendo Sony and Microsoft it's
time to talk about PC video games PC you
own one you're probably watching this on
one right now and also third party
developers there's quite a lot of that
this is going to take a while I'm very
happy to be joined by Cameron Robinson
hey Denny Scotland say something Scotti
from Scotland did you say freedom
freedom thank you say freedom Peter
Brown Freedom nice Dan hin say freedom
freedom great okay aie America
Scottish and Irish actually yours is
cicer to the film really it's the United
color colors of beniton of video games
and we're here to talk about PC which is
perhaps the most universally popular uh
platform if you want to call it that and
then all bunch of other stuff as well
first of all Hardware I want to ask you
first Peter Brown Steam Machines this
seems to be a it keeps coming up every
time we talk about conferences in
particular mhm where are we with steam
machines what the hell is a steam
machine they still haven't made this
like digestible okay a steam machine is
a PC that's effectively priced to
compete with consoles but what it really
is is a machine that runs the Steam OS
and supports valve's controller valve
has now delayed that to 2015 yeah like
everything like everything uh they're
making Inc incremental improvements to
Steam OS um but again it's kind of like
a Linux box right so it doesn't really
support a lot of the games that you'd
find on windows so honestly right now if
you've got steam installed on your
Windows PC and you run Big Picture Mode
and you got a 360 controller you've
effectively got a steam machine yeah so
do there be no announcements whatsoever
from valve in terms of Hardware E3 this
year no I don't think valve is going to
release their own little steam machine
again I think they're incentivizing
thirdparty manufacturers to come up with
stuff that will help them sell hardware
and ultimately help people will help
valve sell more software yeah cool H
Cameron Robinson I know you were at Eve
FanFest in uh wonderful Iceland only two
weeks ago uh about a month ago now
excellent um you were there to see Eve
Eve Valkyrie mainly to see Valkyrie and
also to use the Oculus Rift yes they had
the development kit two there which the
first time I got my hands on that and
yeah I got to play vyy which is now
being it's now being made with unreal 4
and the difference was huge yeah look
great your video preview was great I saw
the side by side yeah it was it was it
was really quite impressive actually
because I was I've played um Oculus
before never Valkyrie on like one of the
older units and putting on the DK2
especially having that like depth camera
like that was the biggest thing for me
cuz I got quite a lot of nausea walking
around that old Tuscan Villa but not in
Valkyrie at all cu you stick it on and
you immediately you look at your avatar
and it really helps like you place and
get that sense of presence so it's is it
judging youing in it's a camera like
about I don't know I me here in front of
you and it it judges your depth so you
can literally lean in towards the
controls or have a dial over there
saying like I don't know your position
you can look at that and your camera
angle changes with that CU before it was
like you had a rod steel rod down your
spine so every time you moved forward
you didn't get that and that was jarring
or it was for me at least it's weird
because this time last year Oculus was
still very much a this might be a piece
of technology that people start to use
since that's happened like we've had
this massive buyou by Facebook um it's
now you know Project Morpheus has been
announced and everything else
what I hate saying this and I know
Peter's going to jump on my neck and
bite my lungs out when I say this is
vior actually not going to be a fat this
time around is this something that
people are we're going to see more and
more of and it'll be like inexorably
tied to gaming yeah I think like the
interesting thing is that it's really
kind of uniting the PC as a platform the
PC has never really had anything at
least at E3 to sort of unify what's on
show um and the fact that you need to
make experiences specifically for VR is
going to actually create something that
is new and sexy and awesome and you want
to see that you know do you think that
developers like the way Eve the guys
there are making falkyrie like
specifically for that do you think this
year we might see some like games made
specifically for with the Oculus in mind
definitely yeah I mean we've got like a
few which um also uh David bra and like
what's it the Name Escapes me no no
Elites danger sorry dangerous is also
Oculus um but I think we are going to
see a few but what I'm really Keen to
see is if we're going to get any which
aren't space sims because that's pretty
much all we see where's my driving game
and where's my I want I want someone to
convince me that a first person game
where I walk around is not going to make
me vomit on the floor like I'm still to
be convinced by that Adam or you know
the guy who was unceremoniously
dismissed from Microsoft after um his
tweet he's working on a game that's
going to be at E3 it's not a space Sim
but you play as a space man in a space
suit that's running out of air so it's
sort of like gravity simulator uh and
that's going to be something that's like
at least a unique firstperson experience
cool all right well let's step away from
the PC for the moment H if you have any
questions for about PC by all means I
keep sending them in but for the moment
let's talk about third party Publishers
first of all EA talking about weird
firsters um video game uh worlds are we
going to see Mirror's Edge to this here
I don't think you're going to see that
and Star Wars Battlefront Battlefront is
definitely going to be there I think
they're going to save Mirror's Edge to
for a bit later and I think there's a
lot further off anyway so well there is
also the question that Microsoft has
this third party exclusive that's
supposed to get people really excited
okay I mean I have a few theories but
Mirror's Edge 2 could be one of them I
think even just teasing that a little
bit more might give them the sort of
excitement that they and the buzz that
they need from the audience you think
that's going to be a Microsoft exclusive
it could be I mean you know they
essentially if they're saying that look
there's a third party game that's coming
that's going to get people really
excited
it's got to be something that we already
know about like in terms of a franchise
right something that people want and
we've literally seen nothing except for
this trailer A3 like nothing nothing at
all so be it'd be great to have but I
almost feel like it might be a better
tactic for them to continue showing
nothing because this trailer was so good
it just reminded everyone that it does
exist and it's a game that you know
everyone it a darling game that everyone
wanted last year unless they're going to
show us loads maybe it would be better
to I think it' be unfortunate if it was
a Microsoft exclusive because this is
the kind of thing you want on
Playstation with Morpheus and with you
know Oculus they obviously that's going
to take a lot of do you want to be
getting sick all over yourself uh yeah I
mean like if you didn't get sick in
Valkyrie I think this could
work I'm a test subject in vomit let's
do it gam SP us to do things like sound
video remember like playability like we
to break down just vomits going to be
what's the puke scale measure in
milliliters that's absolutely rank uh
Star Wars Battlefront definitely think
yeah I definitely think it's going to be
there show it off yeah they said in the
shareholders meeting that it's coming Q2
Q3 201 right so there's a pretty safe
bet that that's going to be shown now if
they're planning what a year down the
road uh what about Battlefield Hardline
we've already seen stuff leaked or Omaha
as they didn't want people to to know
about it um yeah I know they're
announcing some stuff after E3 do you
think it's going to have much of a
presence at the show I think it has to
yeah yeah I think it's just sort of like
a thoroughly underwhelming concept
really I mean like it's it's not a
Mainline Battlefield title and
Battlefield is all about scale and every
time they tried to go like Close
Quarters Urban it's sort of been like oh
okay that's fun for a distraction but if
they focus an entire game on it um
probably maybe something cool can come
out of it I mean I did like the Special
Forces weapons like the grappling hook
and zipline and that kind of thing but
I'm just not really that interested in
what it actually is as we've seen so far
uh Dragon Age any hype for Dragon Age um
well we haven't really seen much in
terms of gameplay I think everyone's
just burned by the previous you know
what was what was the one that nobody
liked two pretty much so this is
Inquisition yeah this is Inquisition I
basically from the trailer it looks like
it's there's a oblivion gate has opened
or they've got some different name for
it that's what it looks like demons are
spilling out onto the world and you
could it could be really great but all
about how they execute the combat and
whether they stick with their their old
what they do best like proper RPG or
whether they're going to try and action
it up again and disappoint people they
can't figure out whether to put a number
on it or origins or a subtitle that kind
of thing it really shows that they
actually don't know what they're doing
without series it's a funny one and it's
changed hands a bunch of time at this
stage as well right it's still BioWare
is it BioWare still well I guess BioWare
has been shaken up so much over the past
couple years it's a little bit different
any love for The Sims 4 there was
another trailer released last week looks
pretty good the goth family got a new
house yo finally The Sims is the kind of
thing that it's like it's going to be
awesome to play but it's not really much
of a presence at a trade show you know
what I mean yeah no you don't think so
but this don't EA do that anyway they us
pump out the the familyfriendly one for
the headline for the mainstream price
like we're obviously going to get so
we're going to get like EA sport UFC the
demo came out
today FIFA 15 presumably some sort of a
like leaning more next gen into that way
what other like games in that ilk like
is this the year where they have to make
a really good Madden for
once it's a they probably should but I
mean will they yeah I don't know all
right let's let's leave EA for the
moment then um a game from uh 2K that uh
see anyone who's played this at a trade
show has said it's absolutely incredible
but it feels like there's hardly any
information about evolve like out there
um have any of you guys played it yeah I
played a few hours of it what's your
what's your take on evolve uh it's it's
almost like they made an entire game out
of the tank combat from Left For Dead
and really sort of like deep dived how
can we make this asymmetric
multiplayer uh work really well and be
balanced as well I think like the
balance is the key thing that's going to
make or break this what I played was
pretty balanced and you do have clutch
plays there are lots of like skillful
moments and that kind of thing um I
think that it's it's going to be a
really really interesting one so which
build did you play cuz recently they
they changed it didn't they they added
the first rild they the so they have
already experimented how they're going
to balance and I like that they are
fible like that because they obviously
know what's going to be you know best
for the titles so yeah so do you think
much of a showing at E3 CU I feel like
they're at the stage where they really
need to start putting into some people's
faces well they' announced they're going
to have a tournament uh on like live
streamed uh on one of the days so yeah I
think it's definitely going to be like
hey here is actual like uncut gameplay
here is how it actually plays in motion
so that's the perfect way to actually
see that and they showed a bunch of P
East as well you know there's a lot of
coverage that came out of that so and
that was a public event obviously right
so people have seen it right now I think
this is right like you said the time to
really put it out there because it's one
of the few games that's coming out this
calendar year that people to get excited
about I guess um Ubisoft they're the
last of the sort of the the big six or
whatever or big five at this stage that
um that have their own press conferences
it seems like most of their
announcements have slipped out early
like Assassin's Creed Unity was the
first one a couple of months ago you
guys excited about that at all I really
want to be but but I'm I'm not I'm
pretty burnt out Assassin's Creed did
you play Black Flag yes I did and the
sailing was great and that was awesome
but every time I had to get out of the
boat I was like oh God not again yeah
kind of i' I've tried like three or four
times to get back in and actually allow
it to grab me and it's just never
happened and this one they don't haven't
even said what is the thing that is
going to make this unique you know so
all we know is right now it seems like
revolutionary Paris and you're an
assassin and that there is a gen version
and then one that is separate that is
coming out on current or come on is that
where we're at the way you think about
ass one no I was going to say I think
that was certainly where I'm at I mean
I've I've struggled to get into an
Assassin's Creed in any meaningful way
since Assassin's Creed two no what was
the third one Brotherhood which was
excellent and then they've all just kind
of disappointed me since then but there
is there is a burnout and uh yeah unless
they were going to like completely
overhaul the combat or how you climb cuz
for me they ruined the climbing when
they made easy I stopped finding it that
fun so unless you're going overhaul
stuff it's it's just a reskin right with
great French accents
maybe um the other thing I guess one of
the more interesting rejuvenations of a
franchise that they've done recently is
is Far Cry Like Far Cry 3 is was one of
my favorite games come out that year
absolutely outstanding they've released
the the concept image of the new one uh
which rubbed some people up the wrong
way uh but presumably they're going to
show some of this at their if I see a
single prompt says you are leaving the
mission area I'm just going to be like
I'm cheing out are you just waiting for
another burn down crops full of weed
while uh yeah well I mean it's weird
like Far Cry as a Series has sort of
been all over the place you know three
was sort of a combination of both
elements of two and one so it seems like
they've found their footing and this is
going to be sort of like Far Cry 3 take
two I think it's Far Cry 3 plus kind of
mountainous snowy areas and hunting snow
leopards like that's what I'm assuming
I'm going to get to do it is the most
bizarre series because the first one was
a like a first person
like we're showing off nice 3D
technology game that came out of Eastern
Europe the second one was an African
malarious Simulator the third was like a
I don't even know what the hell that
game was but it was amazing Beach but Al
but then these weird like story Concepts
that never really worked out but just
kept you guessing um no you just didn't
get it I don't I don't think anyone did
like but I loved it I don't know like
are you guys excited about Far Cry 4 oh
really so much yeah three was my
probably my best game for last year
andity
JBS eleps and rhos as here the Ubisoft
though like they want lightning to
strike twice I mean you saw how they
revealed Watch Dogs and then they
revealed division in exactly the same
way they're going to try and have a new
vas and I don't think they're going to
be able to live up to that because that
was sort of like um flash in the pan you
know like one time thing it was amazing
yeah that presentation was great so
they've got a couple of other games that
I guess are they've got actually got a
lot of games on the go at the moment the
crew is another one they've been
shopping around for a while now have any
guys played the crew not yet no no it
looks like Borderlands in cars yeah I I
feel like it doesn't seem particularly
interesting looks a lot like Rivals for
me as well except the more open world I
mean kind of cops rubbers thing going I
was kind of hoping I get that like
Burnout Paradise Hook from it maybe like
if if it's interesting in that way like
in a new sort of like social way look as
just like fun and carefree you know it's
sort of like uh a big side Peter briyan
what was that was
huge mind I don't it's between Drive
Club and the crew I mean I I you know I
miss like really like racing games and
for me that's the forza and that's Grand
Turismo and I like when those come out
and I just these games that come out
that try to experiment with that they
show up and then they disappear and no
one cares about it yeah and so I have a
really hard time getting excited for
something that's I mean like what what
am I looking at here I don't know car
video game I hope I hope whoever's
working on this is not the same guys who
did the car driving or the the car
driving the the handling models in Watch
Dogs uh fingers crossed H so perhaps the
game that's got the most hype around it
especially in relation to uh E3 in
particular is the division when they
showed it off was it two years ago now
the first time or was it last year year
last year dude shutting car door with
his hand everyone freaking the hell out
um we're not going to see this game for
a while what do they need to show this
year to keep people entertained about I
think the thing is like they're really
good at their first reveals being slow
and sedate and really sort of absorbing
and immersive so what they're going to
show this year is the action side of it
they're going to show massive firefights
and you know those kinds of uh division
vers division engagements that they've
been sort of hinting at at the end of
that first trailer well and one of the
things too like they've been saying I
guess the rumor is that they've been
working so much on the text side of
things that the actual game development
is still pretty early yeah so I'm really
curious to see if what we see this year
will be drastically you know drastically
different from what was presented last
year I don't think it'll be too far off
the mark but I expect it's it's going to
look a little bit different in terms of
the setting and the mechanics and how
everything sort of plays together uh we
got a bunch of questions coming in from
folks I want to just get a few of them
uh done before we continue uh blurred
Cube asks any chance of Rockstar showing
up Rockstar are funny when at E3 they
tend to not usually play that game they
didn't need to yeah yeah so probably no
didn't they say an earnings call that
they had something coming out before uh
the next financial year probably Red
Dead for PC if anything yeah would it be
or would it be or Grand Theft Auto 5 for
PC at this stage no no way because
there's rumors about the nextg GTA 5
there's rumors about nextg Skyrim like
one that might be made specifically for
the they'll do next gen in GTA 5 before
PC GTA 5 I think you don't think they do
them at the same time maybe no no
separate them up yeah uh yeah so it's
weird Rockstar one of those companies
that kind of just do their own thing
they tend not to really need E3 to show
stuff off and another one that chat's
been asking about hasson asks Mass
Effect do we see something a new Mass
Effect this year or at least like a
glimmer at one I think that you may get
sort of like we had with Mirror's Edge 2
at the end of that press conference
you'll probably get um Mass Effect
subtitle whatever it is they're going
with whether it's like the first Contact
prequel or you know hundred of years in
the future sequel um it's probably not
going to be uh playable at all I don't
know if you seen any gameplay but you're
definitely going to get some kind of
teaser I think yeah another game we're
likely to see at either or both press
conferences and probably a lot of in
terms of uh State show presence as well
is Destiny uh Bungie have been sort of
they showed off a little bit last year
that got people excited about it is it
just me or am I is this game not as
exciting as I was kind of I'm not I feel
like I haven't hopped on the hype dra
this one yet I mean that's sort of the
unanimous impression that came out of I
think event that happened about a month
ago everyone sort of got their hands on
it and was like all right it's an MMO
yeah what uh I don't know what's what's
really different here you know and that
sort of seemed I mean the world is
supposed to be interesting right you've
got some of the you know the bungee
things that that are persisting here
from the Halo Universe in terms of
aesthetic and stuff but is it going to
be something great greater than just
another MMO made by bunge they've just
been so vague about how their shared
world and you know connectedness
actually works that I don't really
actually understand how this is
multiplayer how this is single player
and and you know like how these things
all interact and persistent so and I
feel like people maybe feel like they've
been burned on Watch Dogs a bit because
a lot of that there was the hinting as
like these vague Recollections of what
that you know connectedness was going to
be and in the end it was just people can
enter your game if you want them to uh
so yeah I guess we'll see we got a bunch
more games to go through here uh a game
that I am really really hoping is
announced I have heard that it probably
won't be Bethesda have since come out
and said that not going to announce
anything what are the chances of seeing
Fallout 4 teas this year I think pin was
was kind of he kind of confirmed we're
not going to see anything didn't he he
was talking about B was it battlecry
what's the announce some other game that
they're going to be talking about um
which means we're probably not I was
also kind of gunning for a mention of uh
sonor T but that's probably just me but
then if it's no new IP then the rumors
of the Skyrim HD version might still
that could still be a thing if that's a
thing what would you think about that
Cameron who has a weekly show about
Skyrim like you're probably a game a for
like people are interested in that would
you play a PS4 and Xbox One version Sky
no I don't see the point because you
don't even need a powerful PC these days
to play Skyrim that looks great using
EMS and everything like you can build a
pretty budget PC you know I don't I
don't want a HD Skyrim I want a Skyrim
pre-installed with all the most amazing
mod so I don't have to do it myself
right you know that would be more
valuable yeah CU I guess that's that's
like you you guys have been playing
Skyrim now for like three years off the
back of the
fact November three years like
isn't that the problem like I remember
the Unreal Tournament 3 on p on PS3 you
could mod but like just modding on
consoles is never really ever been a
thing no I think it's just too
complicated with um you know the
potential for damaging your your game
and you know that no one wants to be
liable for that so yeah I don't think
we'll see that but um civilizations
beyond Earth anyone anyone hyped up
about that one oh yeah totally I mean I
I haven't played civilization since
three because they've just been twoo
similar I did play alha centu back in
the day and I love civilization I love
space so yeah this this has going quite
excited we don't I want to see I want to
get some proper details about like how
the mechanics are going to work like how
you start it off what type of units
you're going to get how the like
encounters with the aliens that are on
the planet is going to be is it just
going to be like Barbarian encounters is
it going to be different I really want
to get some details but I'm quite
excited you couldn't play as the aliens
and OB centor could you you were just
you were well or the the the I guess it
wasn't really aliens was it it was just
the world yeah like the world elements
like the animals and creatures wasn't it
yeah I think they were just like
encounters basically centor it's been so
long I played a lot of hotland Miami
hotland Miami 2 do you think we're going
to see some of that here we got we've
got to it's it's coming out soon right
that's the thing like at this stage I
feel like it's coming out in a couple of
months right yeah they've been showing
it off it was at PAX East again like
back in April and it was does have a
console exclusivity thing going already
it's I think it's only on play
Playstation and PC right time exclusive
on PS I should have looked this up
before we started I played it on
PC yeah I'm probably going to play it on
PC too let's see a couple more because
the folks here want to want to shut the
show but I want to talk about F1 2014
cuz I know all you guys want to talk
about that Co Masters haven't like even
talked about whether they're doing that
so I'm I'm genuinely interested to see
if they talk about an X gen F1 game
because it look pretty what do you guys
think about that I don't think it needs
to come out every year God damn it of
course it does it's a sports game it's
how it works um is there any other games
that uh you guys are are interested in
you think that square will show a bit
more of the next days X okay yeah days X
Universal whatever they're calling it
they need something to kind of prop
themselves up and I don't really know
what they have yet so they're going to
show some more Final Fantasy 15 for sure
wo which of three well that can get a
lot of people really excited I mean that
game has been in development for eight
years now than there is the wi of 3
that's my that's my most anticipating
thing to see of the whole show I'm want
to see one more which of three awesome
well from the SS of it we've been
talking a hell bunch of mess about video
games for the past hour and a bit uh
there's no shortage of uh cool stuff to
see out of you3 this year so make sure
you stick on gamespot.com all next next
week now it's time to give away some
stuff some some sweet swag so we had we
had this competition uh last week uh
Mary Kish came up with where it was
asked people to make box art for games
that they might like to see so your
halflife threes and your such and suches
so uh these aren't the winners but these
are some other really good ones as well
we had Metroid there Mass red effect
these are flying past take your time
Boys halflife 3 Xbox One exclusive I
think not that game's actually coming
out they just took the logo and made the
Box yeah worthy effort that's Chris
Waters that doesn't count connect selfie
that's a really good one that's not one
of the winners cuz he lives in Poland
but it was pretty rad so we're sticking
it in there uh that guy Drew is that
Vanquish 2 y van I would love a Vanquish
H special points for
making super realistic
Graphics yep sure got it nailed it just
take two seconds on that one there way
too way too many keys on uh yeah sure
Monkey Island I can dig that Destiny and
more and yeah limited edition throw it
all in there bloody Roar four grinning
in his seat right now oh really if he's
watching he probably put that one oh
that's
that's by Mary Kish age n h okay we've
got four hold this stuff so one two and
three three or sorry four three and two
are winning these the winner is winning
both of these bad boys on a laptop a
razor laptop um so thanks to Razer for
for helping us out with that we're going
to have a look at number four
first oh wow congratulations Cameron
harst with your uh racially insensitive
portrayal of Kim jongon and just cause
that's pretty good just end yourself a
Kraken Pro it would yeah it'd be cool I
would like to see Avalanche show off a
new just C game especially if Kim
Jong-un was in it that would be great in
third
place Final Fantasy 15 I know my Roman
numerals crazy kiddos nice work uh bonus
points for um well using fraking archaic
means of drawing things cave painting
when was the last time you used a pen
this morning did you write your rent
check no I I you got do that all right
okay when's Last the pen yesterday today
but I dropped it God damn it in second
place damn
things second
place WWE versus
Capcom special edition is that John Cena
and Ry fair enough so many character
real Mary B nice work you won yourself a
pair of headphones and in first place to
win a laptop and all this stuff over
there
is Hyrule Warriors first place emblem
2007 um Gamespot user there who was uh
spent all day working on this bad boy
apparently impressive it's pretty good
it's pretty nicely done Graphics
congratulations much Graphics wow wow
wow wow so so high
rule it's been a long stream thank you
very much gentlemen H Dan Peter and
Cameron Robinson for coming on and
chatting to me about E3 I'm hyped you
guys hyped oh yeah sure I can't wait
we're flying down Friday Frid Satur
Sunday Sunday Saturday Saturday Saturday
uh we're getting in there we've got um
live streams of all the press
conferences on gamespot.com plus we've
got two stage shows throughout the
entire week myself Chris Waters sha mcus
and Cameron Robertson are going to be
hosting them uh with basically every
single game that will be playable on the
show for so make sure you stick around
on gamespot.com our Hub should be up
pretty soon as well e3. gamespot.com
which will have all the information of
when all that stuff can be on live and
also on demand of course we do not have
a Lobby next week we because you know
e3's on and you know who gives a [__] H
and the week after that then I believe
we're all probably going to be too tired
to do a Lobby so we'll see what happens
then so if we don't see you we'll see
you at E3 have a wonderful weekend and
uh yeah greatness of Weights
[Music]
baby
oh